Yeah, I mean, I had a lot of times when I just RMRF'd my system by mistake, you know?
But every time I came back stronger.
So I had like three times of those iterations.
You RMRF'd your system three times?
Yeah, hold on a second.
That's not like...
Listen, never in my life have I done that.
So I need a little more context.
Yo, Nogli, welcome to the pod, man.
Thank you. Thank you very much. Happy to be here.
Yo, so, okay. I want to start out this episode.
We've got a bunch of questions for you.
And I'm hoping we can get to the recon secret sauce in this episode.
See if we can get them to spill the beans.
But I wanted to start with...
So a while back, you know, I thought I had met Nogli for the first time
or the first talk to Nogli at a live hacking event.
But when we started chatting, Nogli sent me a message or told me that he had sent me a message back in...
What was it? Let's pull up the DM here.
It was January of 2021, which actually is not that long ago when you think about it.
Saying like, hey, can you look at my recon flow?
Can you like validate?
And then he just drops this like massive X mind, like mind map of like pretty much the source...
I mean, it literally has all of the source code, like curl and like all the commands that you're running.
And I'm looking through here and I'm like, wow, this guy is...
Actually, let me see what I said.
I said, dude, that looks freaking sick.
Nice work, brother.
So, I mean, at this time, Nogli, had you done much hacking at this point or were you just like kind of like building out your recon framework?
Yeah, so I didn't do much recon at the time.
I just did some DoD, you know, get some reputation up on my HackerOne account, get some private invites.
I think I got like only $1,000 on HackerOne when I sent you this one.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah, two years and like four months ago.
And I just looked to validate some of my stuff with, you know, the top hackers at the time and just shoot you it all because I don't want my DM to get lost in your...
Yeah, no, and it looked amazing.
And I have to say, even at the time, I can tell from the way that I responded to you, like I was like, oh, oh, dang, you know, because we get as the top hackers, I'm sure you know this now, Nogli, you know, being one of the top hackers yourself.
But, you know, we get a lot of DMs that says like, you know, hey, can you help me with this?
Can you like validate my this and that and the other thing?
And a lot of time, it's like really like basic stuff.
And you're like, oh, okay, but then he drops this whole like mind map with like all of the source code, all of the bash that he's running.
And I'm like, dang, this guy's pretty legit.
And then we had a conversation, you know, following that of like, hey, you know, you might want to architect it like this, you know, actually.
So the advice that I gave you is, hey, I don't really see like a message broker in here.
And so, I mean, did you ever implement a message broker or are you doing some other way to like connect all the parts to your system?
Yeah, not really.
I mean, there are two types of automation hackers.
Either you build the whole DevOps infrastructure with message broker and containers and stuff like that.
I went to the more, you know, just bash scripts, while loops, cron jobs, axiom, and, you know, to the easy route, we could say.
Yeah, I mean, that's kind of like, I think we talked about it a little bit at the live hacking events, but that's, I mean, that's what a lot of the top hackers do.
You know, you'd imagine that these people have like everything written in Rust, like distributed across all the things.
But when you really talk to people, it's like, dang, there's a lot of like bash going on here and like really scrappy systems built up.
So, I just thinking back on this, I'm so glad that, you know, I responded to this message and we got to have that early interaction because look at him now.
He is, okay, hold on.
I've prepped this Noggley, hold on.
He is the newest million dollar hacker.
Whoa.
You hear the cheering?
Yeah, yeah, I can hear you.
Okay, nice.
So, congrats on that, man.
And actually, so, I mean, you said you had made maybe a thousand dollars on HackerOne at this point.
This is January of 2021.
So, you went from having made a thousand dollars in January of 2021 to being the latest million dollar hacker.
Is that right?
Yeah, I barely made any money on 2021.
So, like only in 2022, only last year, it was like since Log4j, it just went off.
Okay, so Log4j was a big pivot point for you or what?
Yeah, I mean, getting some Log4j's, you know, two hours after it was published on Twitter, just got my Noggley scripts running, you know, and it got a lot of like 10k bounties and stuff like that from programs.
It was a good leap forward.
Nice, man.
Wow, that's cool.
So, man, I feel like Log4j was not that long ago.
So, you've really, you know, you've really scaled up quick.
So, okay, my goal for this session is to, you know, try to get some of the secret sauce out of Noggley, try to see how much of his, you know, of his techniques we can, I can pull out.
So, okay, so you said Log4j was one of the big things.
What other kind of, what other kind of vulnerabilities are you poking around for, Noggley?
Yeah, I mean, it was a lot of subdomain takeovers, you know, back at the time, name server takeovers, Route 53, GCP, all those kind of stuff, you know.
Back at the time, you used to get a lot of these.
Now, it's like three to five very like 1k, 2k a month each for me.
Sure, sure.
But just generic vulnerabilities, you know, not nothing really, really spicy at the moment.
I used to, in Vegas last year, I tried to build my EC2 automation, but it's so much hard work.
I know the top hackers are doing it, but I'm not really in that game because it's so hard to maintain.
You need thousands of accounts and there's a lot of money in it.
I know a lot of the top hackers are doing it, but I'm just, okay, I give up on that.
I don't want to stop them.
So when you say EC2, you're talking about EC2 IP takeovers, right?
Yeah, so basically you have a rotation script on your account to try to claim IPs and then you check your recon data and you see if any DNS name points to that selected IP.
And if you get a match, then you claim the takeover.
You've got your recon data and then, you know, you've got that all built out and then you're generating EC2 instances or EC2 IPs, checking the IP and seeing if like any of these DNS records that were out there were pointing to that IP.
And that IP is just getting reused and passed on to a different customer, right?
Yeah.
Gotcha.
Wow.
Yeah, that sounds like a lot.
And I know I actually dabbled in that a little bit and for a little while I had it, you know, generating a couple of grand a month off of findings.
But I think, you know, not too long ago, AWS sort of implemented some sort of rate limiting surrounding that, right?
Yeah, they're trying to ban your accounts mostly and then you need new credit cards, new phone numbers.
I mean, it's a whole operation with just too much time.
I mean, I gave up on it.
That's definitely a lot more, yeah, that's involved in going into that for sure.
Yeah.
Yeah, EC2 IP.
Okay, so you've got that.
You've got, so here's one of the problems that I ran into.
And I think Nogli and Joel, you probably know this, but for the audience, I'll talk a little bit about this.
So at the beginning of my bug bounty career, I was kind of like, I was doing mostly just, well, I guess at the very beginning, I started off building reconnaissance-based stuff.
And I was like, oh man, this is really hard, you know?
And then I started doing just like hands on the keyboards hacking and like diving deep into the application, finding some stuff.
And then I was like, okay, you know what?
I feel like I've got a little bit of a better grip on this now.
Let's go full automation.
So one of the things, so I built out this whole system.
I probably put thousands of hours into building this system.
And it worked great for a couple of years.
But one of the biggest problems that I ran into was getting, and it's especially important for these things like NS takeovers and for like anything related to subdomain takeovers,
is getting a clear picture of the DNS configuration of an organization or an asset in practically real time, right?
Because like, as soon as anything changes, you need to be the one to know, oh, hey, this just went from, you know, NX domain to serve fail right now.
And I need to pull that asset.
So I mean, what kind of tools are you using to get that clear up-to-date picture of the DNS configuration of a, you know, set of assets?
I just use the normal open source tools.
I have some, I modify them a little bit, maybe for some input output for easier, so it will be more convenient for me.
But I didn't develop any, you know, innovative, RUST kind of thing because I didn't find it like, I didn't need it.
I didn't feel like I needed it.
And I used a lot of benchmarking with more channels and doxing.
I mean, it was just fun to compete with them.
We have like a small channel of us, you know, just bashing each other, just comparing our stats.
And it's very nice to have this kind of competition, you know, and do the stuff, but doxing is on the other level.
I know you thrive off of that, Nogli.
I know firsthand that you thrive off of that.
So that's cool.
Yeah, I think having, you know, Joel and I were kind of talking about this last week, having hacker chats, you know, having, sharing with other hackers and talking to other hackers.
Like, you know, a lot of people would say, hey, man, you need to keep your secrets all secret and that sort of thing.
But like, you'd be surprised about how much better of a hacker you, you, you know, become when you start sharing and starting having conversations with other hackers.
Yeah, I believe that 80% of the bugs of the, you know, the good bugs that you submit to programs, it's either automation or collaboration.
I mean, collaboration, you get a lot more insights, better findings.
I think that's like the bigger part of the picture when you see quality bugs and programs.
Yeah.
So I guess this was another route that I wanted to go down.
So I know just in your, in the history of Nogli becoming, you know, what he is today, that there was a big, a big pivot point was that was you starting this thing called Bug Bounty Hunters Guild.
And could you tell me a little bit about that and like how that helped you improve as a hacker?
Yeah.
So I spoke around May or June of 2021, I started getting a little, you know, 10K months with my automation, some segment takeovers.
And then I spoke a lot with doxing and more chat on different Discord chats, you know, just private chats that they would copy paste the text to each other.
And then why won't we just, you know, have a Slack group and just chat with each other and, you know, drop some stuff, some Twitter threads, some interesting things.
So I just started this Bug Bounty Hunters Guild.
It was like five of us maybe or six.
And then just invited more people that we saw over, over the leaderboards, over Twitter, and just, you know, to speak in a more controlled channel.
And it was a great success, not only for me, but for other hackers, they made connections with each other.
A lot of collaborations have gone from that point.
So it was very good for a while.
Now, for every Slack channel, it's decreasing in the, in the engagement over time.
Some other mini groups are created, but it was very good for a year.
And now it's mostly for DMs.
Yeah, and I, and I feel like, you know, at some point you, it's hard to keep engagement in those, in those sort of communities.
But I think it's cool that as you, you know, as probably the fastest zero to a million hacker that I've ever seen, you know, I think it's really cool that a part of that was building a community at the same time, right?
That building a community is like its own, you know, full-time job.
But, you know, you built a community and you were, you know, kind of fostering growth in other hackers and like communicating with other hackers and, you know, trading, trading techniques and stuff like that with other hackers while you were building out your automation framework and getting, getting to that magical number of 10K a month on, on, on automated, automated stuff.
So I think that's...
And they had a full-time job as well.
Yeah, yeah, well, and of course, right, on top of that, you actually have a full-time job, which you just recently quit, right?
Seven months ago, I think that was...
Was it, has it already been seven months since you pulled the plug on that?
Times flies.
Oh my gosh, man.
So you quit that and, you know, I guess you started, you started Shockwave then, yeah?
So you want to talk a little bit about that?
Yeah, it's my own starter.
I mean, I took my services into a product because it's more scalable and I see a lot more value that I can bring to companies, insights when I also connect to their internal DNS stuff and the cloud security posture tools.
Then the biggest task is to find all the subdomains.
So if I can collect it also from the inside, I can run my automation, continuous monitoring more easily.
The point is for companies to have these, you know, automated hackers that hack them every time and also to have a platform for them to collaborate, like to do challenges, to invite researchers.
So instead of giving you DNS zone file, you know, or text files with all the records, let's just invite you to their ASM.
You will see all the assets.
You can collaborate and chat with others, leave notes, and then you could pull, you know, good findings.
And that's like the goal of the, of the product, collaboration and the automation tool for companies.
Wow, that's awesome.
Yeah, that's kind of what you were talking about last week, Joel, with like, with the DNS records, giving the DNS hosts, you know, zone, zone files.
Yeah, there we go.
I couldn't, I couldn't get it out.
Giving the zone files to hackers to, you know, try to eliminate that security by obscurity thing, right?
Yeah, exactly.
I mean, you see too many companies do it where they just hide stuff behind like a weird complex domain or like a bunch of subdomains.
That nobody can find.
Yeah, it gets tricky for sure.
And so, I mean, and on top of that, the platform is designed around, I mean, you're giving them additional recon data too, like ports and, you know, server fingerprinting and that sort of thing, right?
Yeah, everything that I would do with my automation scripts, just hitting a GUI.
I mean, getting out of the command line and also getting the additional insert that I can give them.
Nice.
That's very cool, man.
And I remember, you know, we were at a live hacking event.
I think it was Vegas and you showed me the, no, it was Barcelona.
And you showed me the progress that your developer was making on the front end of the GUI and that thing is pretty, man.
So, talk to me a little bit about, like, how did you go about putting a GUI on this thing and, like, you know, yeah, talk to me about that.
Yeah, it's very hard.
I mean, it's either you develop everything from scratch and then you need a lot of developers, but a single developer in Israel, it's like 150, 200,000 dollars a year.
And I wouldn't, I won't just pour all my money into it before validation and stuff like that.
So, I took a developer from Upwork and I took a bootstrap template, you know, a template I can start from.
And then, you know, I paid some money for a designer to make it look nicer and more with the brand identity.
And then just developing it, like, I mean, I have a vision of, you know, attack surface.
I've seen a lot of products.
I know what we, as Bagmonte answers, what we want to look, what we want to see.
So, just, you know, going from that point, slowly but surely.
Nice, man.
That's, that's really cool.
So, so one of the things that kind of stood out to me there was that you said that you hired a designer.
And so I know, I know you have a coder, but you also had a designer.
Is that correct?
Or is this a same person?
Yeah.
So, on Upwork, like I hired a designer for a small gig and then I hired another one for, to do some LinkedIn post templates.
And, you know, everything that I needed another person, let's just grab someone paying for a short stint for a project and then move on, you know, to grind it like a,
not stopping.
Yeah, I, I, dude, I love that.
I love the use of delegation because like, that is one of the things that I struggle with the most is like handing off things that I am not good at to people that are good at them and then just paying the money.
You know, like it's, it's so, it's such a good efficiency piece.
So yeah, great to hear that.
And, and I also love that, you know, that you did hire an individual designer aside from your coder and gave your coder, you know, for the front end, some, some, you know, some template, some design to some docs to work with.
Because, you know, the coder, the coders aren't always necessarily the best designers and, and vice versa.
Right.
So I, when I tried to bootstrap my own bootstrap, see, that's, that's a nice little pun there.
When I tried to bootstrap my own front end, my front, my own GUI for my, my thing, it was total crap because I mean, I can write front end code, but I can't design front end code.
And so, um, yeah, that was, that was really smart to go about it that way, for sure.
Have you ever noticed like any struggles between getting the designers and the coders to work together?
Like, since you're just sort of both random people?
Um, yeah, so I always like keep my developer, I create more tickets from him in GitHub and I really like detail for him, like very slowly.
Like, he doesn't need to speak with me.
I give him a, um, an assignment and after two weeks he just speaks with me.
I mean, we don't need to, I don't need to talk with him daily, you know, about stuff.
Uh, but I also had some bad experiences with another developer.
I tried to like move everything to react from bootstrap, which sounds like a good idea.
It can protect from XSS and it will be more smooth, you know, the website and stuff like that.
But it was, I mean, it didn't make sense because I developed like in two different lifespans.
He developed a front end for features that we didn't develop yet.
And then, so it didn't make sense.
So I lost like $10,000 for it, but yeah, nevermind.
We'll make it up.
I love that.
I love that, that entrepreneurial spirit.
Like, like I feel like I would get so caught up on that, like, ah, you know, nah, why did I make this terrible move?
Or like, how do I like still stick to my guts on, you know, going to react even when it's not working?
So I think, I think, uh, I think that's a really good indicator of someone who's going to be successful in the entrepreneurial industry is that ability to, you know, quickly adapt, not, not trip over the failures, not trip over the missteps and, uh, and continue rolling.
And I'm sure that's the same thing that kind of got you into the, into the space where you're at with, with recon too, is like, you know, start going down a path, be like, ah, that's not going to be the right approach.
And then, you know, adapt and, and change.
So that's really, that's really good to see.
Yeah.
Um, all right, let's, let's get back to the doc here.
Joel, you got any questions you want to shoot them or should I just go off rapid fire?
Yeah.
So, I mean, you talked a little bit about like your recon and like, you know, doing bug bounty and stuff, but how did you, what was like your path before bug bounty?
What, what led you to like, to bug bounty in the first place and be interested in security and all that?
Yeah.
So I started studying in an open university, uh, computer science, because I always like, like computer science, and I was in the army and the, the final year of my officers, uh, like in my military service, I was in a cyber security department.
And then I was exposed to a lot of cyber security information, not really hands-on, more like in, like to make some slides about attacks and stuff like that, you know,
but I, I got into the world, the world of, uh, knowing attacks and stuff like that.
And then I started, I took a course on Stanford.
It's called web security CS253.
It was, it's kind of advanced course about JavaScript, cookies, XSS, and so on.
But it was a really good for me, no, one practical course just to learn about some attacks.
It has some labs.
So it's very high, I mean, if I will watch it again today, I probably, probably learn new stuff again, but this was like a nice course for me to start with.
And then, I mean, bug bounty, it's, it's good because you don't need anything from the company.
You just need to open belt and, you know, start hacking.
So that's what got me into like investing in that kind of field and not like going to internal pen test, network pen testing, which is, it requires you to have some sort of relationship with the company before.
So, yeah, no, that's interesting.
And yeah, gradual.
Well, and then like, what made you want to eventually shift away from that?
Like what you just talked about, like, it's bug bounty is nice because you don't have to have a relationship with the company, but now as you've gone through bug bounty, now you actually are like creating relationships with companies.
You're doing internal pen tests, that type of stuff.
So what, what drew you away from bug bounty and back towards that other stuff?
And yeah, because I mean, bug bounty, you don't really know how, how you will do next month.
So, I mean, you don't really, you can't predict if you will find bugs and over the course of months, I see that I find less bugs.
I mean, it's of course, many, many more people are trying to do what I do and they are succeeding in it.
So I see that I get less bugs on my automation and that's why I decided also to build my product and I know what I could get from companies with a relationship that will make them actually more secure.
I mean, they are using products like mine.
I mean, they're using it external tax service management, probably, you know, all the Fortune 100 companies that we're hacking.
But still the focus there, it's not really the focus that we find the bugs with and probably malicious actors because they are more focused on outdated softwares, on NIST CVEs, on all of the stuff which are not really exploitable.
And that's the big difference between us and them.
So I decided to maybe try to go over that route as well.
But also, of course, back boundaries, I'm still doing it and grinding what's there.
Gotcha.
So how much time would you say you're spending doing like manual, like looking, finding new bugs, like prodding at a specific product versus just sort of running it through your whole automation suite that already exists and seeing what it returns?
This is the question, man.
I love this.
Yeah.
I barely do any manual hacking and I hate it because I can't focus.
I can't find a program to focus it.
And it's so disturbing.
I mean, in live hacking events, I will always find a bug somehow.
I don't know why.
Because there is a competition.
There is, you know, there is the grind.
There is the environment.
But actually doing manual hacking these days, I barely manage to do it because I can't focus on the program.
I mean, if I will find a good program, I will manage to authenticate to it.
I will do it.
But I can't really force myself to do it.
That's so interesting because like that I've mostly interacted with you in the live hack and we've done a lot of live hacking events together.
So, you know, it's not an insubstantial amount of interaction, but the, you know, I've mostly interacted with you in a live hacking event front.
And that was one of the things I was going to ask you about was like, I feel from my perspective, I see you in live hacking events, right?
Which is when you're like in the zone, you're like locked in, you know, you can really focus because of the competition.
And I noticed that, you know, you're one of the rare exceptions of people that do both recon, hardcore recon, and also hardcore hacking.
Like he is in the authenticated app finding, you know, the, you know, sea surfs and stuff like that, where you have to be authenticated to find it.
As well as also doing this mass scanning and like, look at this weird asset I found, you know, in the middle of nowhere.
And so that's really interesting to hear you say that, you know, your normal approach is actually mostly just the recon and you just kind of pull that out of nowhere for the live hacking events.
Yeah, I don't know why, I mean, I wish I could find some programs, you know, to just go all in on them for a year and make like 100, 200,000.
Yeah.
I know it's possible probably if I would focus, maybe if I would have a friendly competition with someone, but it's hard.
I mean, if anyone manages to figure how to incentivize, like to make us, force us to collaborate on a program, it could be very good to hear.
Yeah.
I mean, that's something I've been trying to figure out forever.
I have the same problem where it's like live hacking event, something about like timing and pressure and just opportunity makes it so ripe for finding good new bugs.
And then even if you were like to come back a month later and try and hack the same program, you might have like no luck or you might just like not have that same kind of energy or motivation or like creativity or anything like that.
And I see that all the time where I'll be like, I don't really want to hack on that.
Comes up in a live hacking event, I'll spend like a month hacking on it and I'll be like, that was a lot of fun.
And then I'll like either come back and I'll be obsessed with it or I'll like never want to hack on it again.
Yeah, I feel like I do the same thing even with like the post event stuff because I'm always like, you know, at the end of the event, you still got a list of things that are like, ah, these things are kind of sketchy.
Like I, I should definitely go back and poke at these a little bit more, but then like, you know, I've got to take a break after the live hacking events too.
Right.
So you take a couple of days and then you come back and you're like, man, this target is like awful.
You know, and you don't, you don't think that when you're at the live hacking event.
So it's definitely something really cool that, uh, you know, the, the platforms have going on for them there.
And it's always, you know, it's, it's, it's mostly not new scopes.
It's just, it's usually the same scopes and the most hardened programs.
You have to, yeah, that's what I want to know.
Yeah.
So on that topic, like you hack on a lot of different programs, a lot of different scopes, all that kind of stuff.
Do you take notes in any type of structured way?
Like how do you keep track of stuff?
Is it all within shockwave or?
Uh, yeah.
So it's very hard to keep notes.
He puts it in a DM to me is what he does.
Oh, oh, oh, just add me to that.
I'll, I'll help keep track.
Yeah.
I just shoot every piece of information to everyone that I, uh, that I can.
But on the last event on, uh, Epic Games, um, could we say the name?
I think we could.
If not, I'll bleep it.
You're good.
Okay.
So, uh, we actually, I collaborated with a Space Raccoon and Alex Wilson.
So we used some sort of a markdown collaborative just to shoot everything on a markdown so everyone could see.
I still don't have anything on shockwave.
I'm still developing.
So we could leave notes on assets, you know, then you could, if you want to share credentials, if you want to say specific things to a HTP server, then you could really easily see it and, you know, communicate with each other because it's very hard.
I mean, I don't know how do you, how you collaborate.
I know Justin is usually like, soloing and then just getting all his leads and then, you know, trying to collaborate on site or, and we got very nice bags on Austin as well on site on a couch, just popping a crate out of nowhere.
That was so fun, dude.
Right in front of the fireplace.
Yeah.
So it's very hard, I mean, to maintain all the notes and of course it's very useful, but I'm not doing it very well at the moment.
I feel like, I mean, Joel, I don't know what you think about this, but like, I don't, I don't know a bug bounty hunter that says anything different than what Noggle just said.
Like pretty much everyone's like, yeah, you know, I really should take notes, but actually I'm garbage at this.
And so like, I don't know, do you, do you, I mean, do you take notes, Joel?
Do you know anybody who takes like really meticulous notes?
Meticulous notes.
I don't think I know of anybody who takes them.
Personally, I don't either take like meticulous notes.
I just take notes sometimes and it depends on the structure.
So like sometimes I'll just do like a Google doc or a Google sheet or something and I'll just dump stuff in there.
If that's like a good format.
Other times if I'm just hacking alone, I might just have a text file in like VS code that I just leave on my other monitor and I just sort of dump thoughts and like bullet points.
I don't think I've really gotten any further structure than that.
I know a lot of people like to use notion and stuff.
That's pretty cool.
I just, I don't really want to like get to the point where I'm getting distracted by formatting and writing my notes and all that kind of stuff while also trying to hack, right?
I want it to be something that's functional.
Yeah, exactly.
I just like write some crap down on this thing and then I like throw it in the garbage the next day.
I'm holding a yellow, I forget we're on a podcast medium sometime.
I'm holding just a yellow like legal pad and I just, you know, I just write like exactly what you said, Joel.
Just like write random ideas down there and then I just throw it away, which is so like, you know.
I do that with the sticky notes.
He's got the sticky notes right there.
So it's just like, I don't know.
I feel like that's, that's, I feel like maybe that's something we could do better and it might be better when like I have find some really good like AI note-taking thing where I can just like brain dump from a voice and have it like auto-generate some cool notes or something like that.
But for right now, you know, I haven't seen, well, a lot of, a lot of really talented Boke bounty hunters listen to this pod.
So let us know on the comments on Twitter, um, on this, on this episode drop, if you, if you guys find, if you guys really do take good notes or if you found a really good system for that and if it's really added a lot of value because, um, from right now, from what I can see, it hasn't really done a lot for, for most other hackers.
So yeah.
Yeah.
Something that allows you to like, I don't know, maybe there's a product somewhere, like a product idea in here somewhere, right?
But it needs to be like something that's like easy to use.
You can just sort of dump like any type of data in there and like, just needs to be easy to like manipulate and format.
I don't, I don't know what, you know, but like something like that at some bridge between like a physical notepad and like a Google doc.
I'm not, I'm not sure.
So we used, we used hackmd.io for, uh, it's just a markdown.
You just, you put your markdown, it's, it's nice, but of course, I think we need something better, but it's just a markdown you could see when everyone is editing and stuff like that.
Yeah.
I think you actually sent me something on this at some point.
Yeah, probably.
Yeah.
When we go with the report for the collaboration.
This looks pretty good, man.
Yeah.
I think this might be, this might be something that we need to, you know, stay on top of because yeah, as long as it's got real time and marked, I mean, that's pretty much like the two things you need real time and markdown.
And I think it does have that.
So that's pretty, that's pretty baller.
It might have to use this more when I do collaboration.
Cool.
Yeah.
Okay, cool.
So that's a, that's a pretty good, uh, we just sort of came up with a little note, note taking
strategy, I might have to try that out.
Um, what would you say the like biggest thing that you've learned over the last, you know,
three years, especially from the escalation point, starting at like January, 2021, like what, what, what are the biggest changes that you've made between like then and now that are like large structural changes to your hunting process?
Mostly you learn a lot by trying to find bugs and not finding them.
Then you know what to skip, you know, I mean, probably at the beginning people would look at CSS files and, you know, and just try to find bugs on them because, but there shouldn't be any bugs on CSS files.
So it's mostly to grind a lot, everything on Twitter, I digest into my mind, just trying to, to figure out if there's anything interesting, just, you know, just hacking and seeing all the new techniques that come.
And networking is very important, you know, to speak with people, to know how to control your temper.
Sometimes when a program is, is giving you some, you know, not the bounty you, you expected or some other stuff that you can't control.
Then if you can't control it, you can't control it.
And so that's some good stuff, you know, to take into, into, into, into concept, into consideration.
It's hard, man.
Uh, when you, when you get a really disappointing thing in the, in the beginning, but I think, uh, I think, like you said,
trying and failing is some of the best ways to grow.
And that's so hard to tell newbies in the space.
Cause they're trying to think about, you know, whether they've got what it takes to succeed in the space.
And, you know, if you just tell them, yeah, just keep on failing and failing and failing and failing, then it's like, you know, what are they going to do with that?
But I mean, that's how it is.
So.
Yeah.
So do you find most of your like new stuff on Twitter or like, how do you ingest like new techniques, new types of bugs, new stuff to add to your automation?
Mostly Twitter.
Uh, I have a feed to my email, to my spam email about all, every new nuclear template because there are too many, but just see if there's anything new with my tech stack.
So I could just fight over sometimes people reach out to me and when they have a zero day misconfiguration and then, you know, they just, they tested all the programs and now they tell me.
So I tell them, okay, you can just give me the software.
Don't give me the POC before I find anything.
And then, uh, when I find new stuff, we collaborate 50/50.
So it's good.
Uh, it's good model for me for them.
It's win-win.
And so that's also people just reaching out to Nagly with zero days.
Yeah.
I mean, to be honest, I've done that.
And that's kind of like Nagly is one of my go-to guys for that is, you know, just toss them, toss them a, uh, identifier for the, you know, vulnerable version or whatever.
And he's like, yeah, I've got like 60 of these, which ones, you know, and, and so, um, that's always been.
Then one year later, another one pops, you know, Jeff.
Exactly.
And I mean, like still to this day, and that's another thing, you know, that you do it with the Grafana bug, right?
I'll just call it out.
Cause everyone, everyone has already seen that bug, but I mean, Nagly still messages me.
I think the last message you sent me was like three weeks ago of like, Hey, another one popped up.
Here we go again, bro.
You know?
And, uh, and so I always appreciate that.
And so that actually leads me to, to wonder how many of your bugs are like collaboration versus, you know, your, your own stuff.
Do you think, you know, you've got a decent, like, what's that ratio of likes people come coming to you with bugs and versus your own stuff?
Uh, I don't know.
So I had one very good collaboration with, uh, from, uh, from, uh, from Yes We Hack, if you, if you know him, it's very good under.
Nice.
Uh, we made a lot of stuff.
One time with, uh, Mo Chan, we were in a Paris Vacking event with Yes We Hack.
We just sat in a restaurant, we drank lemonade, you know, and then he just told me about the one time he got a lot of takeovers from a, from a vendor.
And then I told him, oh, why won't I just sign up to that vendor?
And then we made 64k out of that simple lunch.
Uh, so that was a fun one.
Uh, sometimes I get collaboration, sometimes not, but, uh, I, I don't know.
I mean, it's, I did, I did a lot of bugs with, uh, with collaborations with each other.
Wow.
That's awesome, man.
That's awesome.
Um, are there other, are there areas like specific topics that you feel like you're really lacking knowledge and you want to spend time like learning and expanding?
Yeah, probably mobile.
Uh, you have your previous idea.
I didn't, I didn't hear your previous idea.
Why do we have an episode for you?
Yeah.
Two even.
So I actually listen to the episodes in the gym all the time.
But this one, maybe I don't want to listen to in the gym because I want to install stuff or see some stuff, you know?
So for the next live hacking event, I also make, I might need some mobile, uh, knowledge.
So that's an area that I'm, I'm looking to go further in then that's probably it, I guess.
Nice.
Cool.
Well, you can always hit me up, dude.
Joel is like, I always hit Joel up for mobile stuff and he's just like the wizard of knowledge with that.
And if he, there's the bonus, here's the bonus thing.
That makes collaborating with Joel so great is if he doesn't know, then you have just sparked him.
You have nerd sniped him to go figure out what it is because I'm going to get instant nerd sniped.
He's not, he's not the kind of guy that should be like, oh yeah, not really sure.
See ya.
You know, no, let me know what you find out.
Yeah, no, it's going to be like, huh, not sure.
And then you get a message five minutes later.
Hey, I think it might be this 10 minutes later.
I think it's, no, maybe it's this, you know, and it just goes down that hole.
So I always appreciate that.
I mean, not everyone, not everyone can do that, but I, it's always, it's great when, um, when, you know, you've got another brain like Joel's to work on it with you and kind of, you know, work, work to the end of problems.
So I think that's one of the reasons I enjoy collabing with Joel so much and asked him to do this podcast is, you know, we, we really, well, to put it concisely, he's nerd snipeable.
Well, I mean, it's funny because we've had all these conversations about like collaboration and stuff and so much of bug bounty, like really good bugs ends up being collaboration.
Yeah.
I think a part of that is just that it takes a lot of different perspectives and smart minds to attack a problem from a different perspective to come up with those different ideas.
Right.
So, um, you know, you're sitting in a, in the coffee shop in France and you're chatting with this, this other hacker, like, Hey, how can we find this?
He's like, Oh yeah.
And you know, I did this thing.
And then you have this unique idea, right?
Why don't we just sign up for it?
And like those types of things, like it might seem obvious, but like, it just takes that extra perspective and that extra like experience that you have had to, maybe you've done that in the past.
Right.
And it might work on this target or maybe you were just, you know, you saw a video or something and you thought, Oh, maybe that'll work here.
And so that, that amount of combined experience and that combined like context altogether is what I think like really makes the in-person collaborate.
I mean, it doesn't have to be in-person, but like collaboration in general, just like really elevates your bugs.
Yeah.
I mean, you don't have to know everything.
I tweeted like two years ago, like a phone book, you know, I have my own phone book to, to message anyone, you know, I have a friend of Vishay.
So he doesn't do much back boundaries, but he knows how to find XSS everywhere.
I mean, no matter the target, no matter how, so it's very, you know, convenient and other sub domain, another endpoint, here is XSS, you know, this kind of stuff.
So it's, I mean, I have a phone book for anyone.
I will reach out for a certain, you know, kind of thing that's tabell upon.
So that's, that's also very nice if you don't, you can't learn everything, you know, so just play to each one's strength.
Yeah, for sure.
And, and I think in addition to that, everyone doesn't, you know, each individual person has their own holes in knowledge as well.
And those also can be helpful.
This is what I tell my mentees a lot too, is like, you know, you bring a new perspective to this target that I don't have because I've got trained eyes and I've got experience, you know,
looking at this thing before and think, you know, that's never been vulnerable in the past.
So it's never going to be vulnerable again.
And sometimes, you know, these, these newer people don't have that.
So they start going down this path and then, and then, you know, a lot of times they'll show me stuff.
They'll be like, Hey, this feels kind of odd.
Right.
And I'm like, yeah, I've seen that like a thousand times and I have never seen it do that actually.
And so, you know, it's really just to encourage any, any of the new people that are listening here is like, you know, you, you think you can always
ping, you know, an experienced hacker and be like, Hey, you know, is this, is this, you know,
something that I should look into or not something that I should look into ensure there, you know,
a lot of times we're going to all come to the same conclusion, but there's,
there's a lot of value in going through that process and understanding because we miss stuff,
you know, Joel missed stuff.
Natalie missed stuff.
And, and you're, you're the listener.
You, you have a unique perspective that we don't have, and that will lead you to find bugs.
And that, and that's okay.
Hold on.
I got to calm myself down a little bit here because I'm getting more hype.
This is how at the live hacking events.
He's going off.
I'm going off, man.
Are you ready for this?
Here it comes.
No, but this is how at the live hacking events, like you said, Joel, they're hardened targets.
And we always, always drop crits and destroy the target, like without fail.
And, and so it's like, you know, time and time again, so many eyes have been over that,
but each individual person brings a new perspective and, you know, can drop new crits
or find new pathways where, where exploitation can happen.
So anyway, sorry, I went, went, went, went full, you know, bug bounty evangelist there,
but you guys, you know, you see, you see what I'm saying, right?
Yeah.
I mean, I think you can raise some great points.
Like first, like the whole trained eyes thing that happens to me all the time.
And like, I'll think like, oh, there's no way that could happen.
Or like you'll, somebody will describe me, but you'll describe it, but to be just,
we'll be talking and be like, Hey, I have this weird behavior over there.
Are you sure?
And like, I'll immediately like think like, I'm not sure about that.
And then like, it's, it, you know, it ends up being the case.
I think the most recent case was this import thing.
And like JavaScript, there's like this import function and it's like the whole trained
eye thing is like, you know, if you just get too comfortable, like being like, oh,
I've seen that before.
I'm pretty sure I know how this works.
Like that, that new perspective of coming in and being like, I have no idea how this works is
like great to just expand your, like your mind a little bit, you know, just like think more
about the problem.
Think, is this possible?
And try those different things that you wouldn't have ever tried before.
Okay.
All right.
We, we, I totally agree with that.
And I could vibe on that all day, but I'm going to bring us back in.
I'm going to get us back to the doc.
I'm going to get us back to optimizing the time with not we here.
Yeah.
And then Joel and I can just rant about that on a different episode.
But, um, okay.
So this is one that I had on there and this is, uh, I'll, I'll explain.
Okay.
So let me just say the question.
What I want to ask is how much of your time do you spend coding versus hacking Nugly?
And I think I know the answer to this, but this was my problem with the recon game, you know,
and, and I think we talked about this actually at a live hacking event, Nugly, but my problem
was that I really enjoy going up against a hard hacking problem and solving that.
And when I was in the recon game, I felt like I spent 80% of my time and
maybe it's cause I'm a shit programmer, but I felt like I've spent 80% of my time coding
and much less of my time actually exploding.
So, I mean, what does that ratio look like to you and how do you feel about that ratio?
Yeah.
I mean, I had a lot of times when I just RMRF'd my system by mistake, you know, and like,
but every time I came back stronger.
So I had like three times of that iteration, of those iterations, but it's a lot.
You RMRF'd your system three times?
Yeah, hold on a second.
Listen, I never in my life have I done that.
So I need a little more context.
I mean, one time, the last time, it was like two years ago, maybe.
And it's just, I ran Axiom and I wait for the results.
And then I can't log into my, to my server.
I mean, it's just password not working.
And then somehow we train RMRF.
I don't know why.
I don't know how.
And then I, since then I modified my Axiom and I never updated it for like one year and a half.
So my Axiom is like not updated because I can't risk having RMRF on my system.
But now I do, this is why I have today 20,000 commits on GitHub.
Because I, I backup my code and my record data every 30 minutes.
So that's like what I did because of that.
But it's a lot of bug fixes.
A lot of, it's like you said, a lot more time to fix the codes and the trivial stuff that are not working instead of hacking.
Or sometimes you add a domain and which is 1 million subdomains, 10 million subdomains.
And it blows up your automation.
So there's a lot of edge cases that you need to take care of when you want to have the one that you don't need to worry.
I mean, I can fly for a week now and nothing will happen.
So that's takes a lot of time to, to reach that level.
Yeah, it absolutely does.
And, and I mean, do you, I mean, obviously we're all hackers, but do you, do you consider yourself?
I mean, from a day-to-day basis, do you think you spend more time coding than hacking?
Um, no, I'm, I mean, most of my stuff already coded.
I mean, I, all the Python scripts, all the best scripts, all the security mindset.
Every time I see new features that can be automated, I will code it.
But mostly I'm researching today, you know, just seeing new stuff that pop up, hacking.
I mean, I don't have any, much more to contribute in the coding part.
I mean, I don't know how to code Django for my system back and in front.
I wish I knew, but like that's, it's hard.
Even with chat GPT, it can help you a lot, but it can't help you with the whole architecture, you know, of, of everything.
But yeah, I mean, chat GPT literally converted all my best scripts to Python, for example.
I mean, just copy, paste, copy.
I mean, you need some iterations, but that's very, it's very good use case if you want to transform to another language.
It's not good for complex architecture, back and front of servers, but for, for all scripts, it's very, it's very easy to use.
Wow.
So do you have plans to integrate AI like into your product at all?
Or what's the plan?
Yeah.
So I have a simple integration when you add a report.
So we take your title, the severity and the end point.
Then I could, I could guess what you want to report with references, with AI.
So it's like, if you report a gray log log for J, you will see, the AI will know the references for the patch and stuff like that.
So that's like a cool feature.
And another cool feature, I mean, auto triage.
It's something I plan.
If you, if my, my clients will make a VDP page or BBP on their website, and they will submit a bug.
Then I will give it a keyword, let's say of a SSL or a, you know, a mail config, you know,
all those kinds of stuff that you don't want to see.
You could just very easily have an AI that detects it.
So, you know, for those kinds of stuff, auto triage, I think it's very good.
For literally finding new bugs, I don't have any use cases yet with automation.
For JavaScript files, it's probably very good to analyze JavaScript files.
Yeah.
But I don't see any, I mean, it can't make my stuff faster for now.
So in that front, mostly JavaScript files, I think can be very good to analyze it.
Yeah.
JavaScript files would definitely, seeing someone spin something up that like,
the problem is, you know, they're so long, you know, and so.
Yeah.
You need to make a lot of.
And you know, you can't just dump all of that into JATTT all so easily.
And even when you do, you're, you're hitting, you're probably,
you're definitely going to hit the chat GPT token memory limit, you know,
where it doesn't remember the stuff you put in from the beginning.
So it's not going to be as simple as like, just using the API,
dumping all the pieces in and saying, hey, tell me about what I just dumped in there.
I think it's got to be a little bit more complex, but when it is,
that is going to be helpful.
That is going to be really helpful.
Yeah.
Um, because nobody likes reading minified JavaScript.
It makes our eyes bleed.
We know.
Um, so yeah, that would definitely be cool.
Cool.
So Nagli, you, you travel a lot, right?
Like you, you're always going to live hacking events.
I always see you on planes and all that kind of stuff, right?
Is it?
Yeah.
Is that pretty accurate?
I mean, yeah, I traveled like to 10 live hacking events last year.
Um, I think it started with Dubai, Paris, Denver, Austin, Vegas, uh, Singapore,
Barcelona, Copenhagen, and then Florida.
This is, so it's like, it was like 10, I think.
So that's crazy.
I think that's a lot of planes.
Yeah.
I've done that.
I've done 10 in a year as well.
And that is a, that is a, that is a grind.
That is a grind for sure.
Um, when you're on planes, are you hacking?
Are you coding?
Are you bug fixing?
Are you sleeping?
Podcast?
What do you, what do you do on planes?
Yeah.
I, I mean, I buy the wife, you know, most of the flights to the U S like 15 hours.
So I buy the, I try to code a little bit, but usually I will just, you know, uh, watch some
Netflix and, uh, if, if I buy myself business, maybe I'll try to sleep, but I, I, it's hard to,
you know, to commit in plane to code or to, to do some stuff.
But, um, yeah, I mean, it's, it's pretty hard to do it on the long flights.
Got it.
So would, would you say a lot of your money goes to business class upgrades?
That's where that, that million is going so fast.
He's flying business class across the ocean.
Yeah.
No, not much.
I mean, mostly it's premium economy.
Sometimes I allow myself to fly, uh, you know, in the Emirates, I mean, I had to experience it
once and why not?
I mean, I don't spend my money anywhere, so I should spend it on something.
Cool.
Yeah.
No, that was actually one of our questions.
It was like, what, where's all the money go?
Cause it's like billion dollar hacker.
Yeah.
Falling out of control.
Right.
Like what's going on?
Yeah.
Uh, yeah.
So I don't, I mean, I'm very conservative.
I could say, I just, all my money now is mostly on money market fund.
It's like 5% a year, very solid.
I can cash it out whenever I want.
And I didn't buy any real estate or any, you know, major stuff.
It's mostly paying for my expenses when I'm traveling, uh, eating in restaurants, you know,
and, uh, and for the flights and hotels.
And, uh, yeah, maybe in the future, you know, I buy some, uh, you know, some cool stuff.
Save it up for the private jet.
We, we, we, we have a different idea of conservative.
Cause Nogley's like flying.
And he says, most of the time it's premium economy.
I wouldn't go down to super basic economy.
Like, Hey, listen, listen, you gotta spend 15 hours on a plane.
You gotta, you gotta draw the line somewhere.
Okay.
Yeah.
It's true.
No, I don't know, man.
I like, I don't know.
I, they're just not that uncomfortable for me.
Maybe, maybe it's cause I'm like, like perfectly the average, you know, height dimension, you know,
sort of guy.
And so everything was designed for me, which is really nice.
But, um, but like, I don't know.
I sit in this, this seat and then I open my laptop and I do some stuff.
And then I, I mean, even on the flights to Japan, it's not that bad.
So I, I don't know.
I, I, uh, I, I never invest in the, in the business class.
I mean, do you, Joel?
I feel like you're the same dimensions.
I, I definitely, I definitely do sometimes.
Like, it depends.
I think for me, the line is like anything over eight or nine hours, I'll probably upgrade
to at least premium economy.
And depending on the price of the upgrade, I might go to business.
Yeah.
Just because like, ah, that's like a full day of just like sitting in a cramp chair,
like next to a bunch of people, just like, you know.
Ian Carroll has a formula.
He told me, you know, Ian Carroll, he flies first class all the time.
So he told me $100 for an hour.
It's what you should pay if you want to fly business.
I mean, maximum for the upgrade.
So it has like very specific formulas.
The, if you want to calculate if it's, if it's worth it or not.
You know, it's kind of interesting though.
Like he, when you say it like that, even I don't really like, you know,
you're paying a hundred dollars an hour to be transported across the world.
And slightly more comfort.
It's actually not that.
I mean, that's pretty good.
You know, like, I don't know.
So that depends on perspective, right?
Like, I think the most expensive business upgrade I ever did was to Singapore.
And that was like, yeah, but it's like for, for me from SF, even like from west coast,
it's like 19 hour flight there.
Yeah.
It's like 19 hours.
Like, what do you do in a, in a, in a tube for 19 hours?
Like I want to recline.
That's what I want to do.
Like, I don't know.
No, that, that, that makes sense.
I, I think, I don't know.
Maybe, maybe we'll see someday, especially.
We're going to convince Justin's flying first from now on.
Let me just go upgrade my, my flight upgrades really quick.
Clickety clack me.
Um, but, uh, but also, you know, Hey, United's got a bug bounty program.
And I will say, uh, you know, just to be fair, because this is how we do it here.
I haven't had the best experience with the United bug bounty program,
but the bounties are great.
You know, if you get, if you get the bounties, the bounties are really good.
Um, as far as like how far those points go.
And especially if you're, you know, you know how to get.
Now I'm, I've really showing my, my, my conservative side.
If you know how to get the super economy saver deals,
then you can get some really good, um, you know, redemption rates for those points.
So they do, they do, they do tax you on them, which is a little bit of a bummer.
If you're a U S citizen, but this is another hack.
You heard it here and it's not tax advice.
You can just write them off as well.
If you use them for business.
So, um, you know, that's, that's kind of the way I've been,
I've been dealing with it and who knows, maybe I should,
I should splurge a little bit more and go, uh, and go business sometime.
I'll have to check that out.
Yeah.
Well, while we're talking about flights, Andy and Carol, you mentioned, um,
that he has like a calculator and stuff.
He also has that site, um, seats dot arrow.
And that's like all around points.
Yeah.
He has this website called seats dot arrow.
And it like, it looks for basically like last minute, like airlines like to sell off their,
their empty seats at like basically mile only rates for like,
it'll be like 40,000 miles plus a hundred dollars or $10 or something.
And instead of like a full size first class ticket.
And if you are, you know, looking for a flight and you have the points for it,
you can usually snag those up like pretty last minute, like for pretty cheap.
Um, and so he has a whole like website to track all that stuff.
So if you're hacking on United and you have a lot of United points
and you're looking for a good way to spend them,
seats dot arrow is probably a good way to find some of those flights.
This is his site.
Yeah.
No way, dude, way to go.
This is awesome seats dot air.
So S E A T S dot A E R O.
Seats dot arrow.
Yep.
Huh.
Pretty dope.
Yeah.
Ian flies a lot.
He's a, he's a cool dude.
We should, we should try and have him on here sometime.
Cause that man is, uh, he's doing a million things at the same time.
It's so cool.
Yeah, for sure.
And I didn't, I didn't know idea that he could program as well.
This is this, this website that very much gives me, um, what's that guy's name?
Was it like links dot IO or something like that?
Links dot IO.
Yeah.
Hold on.
I don't know if I, we're getting, we're getting off the hacking topic here, but there's this guy,
links dot IO that does, uh, AI.
Let me see if I can find it.
I can't find it right now, but he does like AI.
Um, he does nomad list.
That's the, that's the new bad list.
And.
Oh, levels are your name on Twitter.
What is it?
Levels are your level.
That's what it was.
Yeah.
Thank you.
And I just, if you look at all of his sites, he talks about how, like, he just really.
Like quickly spins stuff up and like.
He has a PHP end point that shows in like he's a, he's a MRR.
And they'll start, you know.
Yeah.
And that's so cool.
Like if I was going to be a creator, I would definitely go down this route.
And also, you know, he talks about how he just iterates with all.
He just does jQuery and bootstrap and, and PHP on the back end.
And he just pushes out these amazing sites.
So this Seats.Aero really gives me that sort of indie levels, levels IO.
Indie hacking.
Yeah.
It's a, it's another one of those like experienced, like trained eyes versus amateur eyes thing.
Like if you're, if your eyes get too trained, you start to like,
like if you say I want to write one of these, I would absolutely spend way too much time,
time trying to make it perfect and like nice for the user and whatever,
instead of just keeping it simple and just iterating on it.
Yeah.
Yeah, absolutely.
Um, all right.
We are approaching the hour mark here.
Let me see what else I got on the list.
Uh, if I don't have too much else, then we might have to go into those, um,
vulnerabilities that we were talking about.
Um, okay.
Actually let me ask this.
So, you know, you said the tech stack is largely bash.
So let me just, I'm just going to check this, this fact.
So bash, you've got, um, you've got, you know, you're wrapping, uh, the actual other, other tools.
Right.
And then you said you have Django for, for, um, that's for shockwave, but you weren't using
that at all before.
It was just, I'm still not using it for my, uh, for my, you know, my automation for bank bounty.
It's just Python bash, uh, axiom, digital ocean, you know, you know, and like text files.
Uh, yeah.
Text off of course.
Text files.
Now, like where do you store all the database, bro?
I have folders.
I have, uh, for the recon dash assets dash, all domain dash.
So you're telling me I could be a millionaire with TXT files and folders.
Holy shit.
Oh my gosh.
And it's only input output.
I mean, where is the, I mean, why do you need a database to read and write?
I don't know, man.
I just feel like, you know, even when I was using back in the day, I used Mongo
because it was just really handy, but like I was kicking myself for not utilizing like,
you know, a real SQL database, you know, like my SQL or something like that with,
you know, all these different relational queries you can do.
Trained eyes.
Yeah.
And you know, boom, he just goes straight for the bash and TXT files and a lot of other.
Grep, Grep is a good one.
Yeah.
Grep, Grep.
He says, oh yeah, for the database.
I don't know if you ever heard of this.
It's pretty unique.
It's called Grep.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh.
That's good.
Um, all right, cool.
Well, you know what?
We can't get anything out of them from the stack because there's nothing in the stack.
It's just, yeah, it's just like, I can't get more simple than this.
He's like telling us how it all works.
He's like, what do you want from me?
He's like, actually just breathe back.
I'm fluent in bash.
He just speaks bash to the computer and it understands.
Um, okay.
So let's talk about the, uh, let's talk about the reports a little bit.
Um, I'm going to go ahead and let's see.
So yeah.
Why don't you start off with the web cache, uh, deception one, Nogli.
So anyway, let me, let me just explain this to the audience real quick.
So, you know, when the guests come on, we want to have, we want to have them talk about reports
rather than our reports that we are quickly burning through on, on the podcast here.
So we're going to have Nogli talk about a web cache deception, uh, phone that he found on chat GPT,
which totally blew up on Twitter.
And then also a, uh, a SSRF from a live hacking event that we've done recently that we will not
share the name of the target for Nogli.
Nogli, uh, otherwise I will have to bleep it, but yeah.
So hit us with the web cache deception one, man.
Yeah.
So lately, you know, uh, we, we are in a kind of a discord with Sam Carey and well,
and just, you know, looking for random targets once every few days to hack.
So it was chat GPT day.
They just introduced the, the plugins and it was very exciting.
So I just said, why not look at it for a little bit and with that, and then I never actually,
I mean, I found cache deception sometimes on live hacking events.
In Denver I found it and I think on another one, but I never tried the bypasses, you know?
So I saw, I saw some stuff, how it powers, how it authenticates you with the chat GPT and stuff
like that.
And then I saw this API endpoint that just gives you your JWT and all your authentication,
authenticated data.
And I thought, well, let's see if it caches.
I mean, I read some write-ups.
I know that you, if you can add static files and the endpoint still, you know, functions the same
and you could still get a hit.
So you have a bug here.
So I just, you know, just tried test.css and oh, I got a hit from the cache server.
It means there's something here.
So it was pretty straightforward.
Just shoot him an email in four minutes.
He answered to me.
I wish they had a bug bounty program.
It's probably like 10 minutes.
Yeah.
Four minutes.
Oh my gosh, dude.
If we could get that sort of response in like actual bug bounty programs, that'd be crazy.
And then let alone you just shot this guy an email.
Yeah.
I know that guy was, he was managing one of the biggest programs in the background.
The guy who manages open AI VDP now.
Really?
Yeah.
I bet they will have a bug bounty program soon.
So probably I lost like 10 to 25,000 if it was a P1.
But well, the exposure and you know, the publicity was very good for it.
And it was a very fun bug, you know, to find a bug on the early days of AI and those kind
of systems.
It's very cool.
And there's a lot of web bugs to find all those stuff for sure.
Yeah.
Wow, dude, this, this tweet really, really blew up.
So you did get some good exposure there.
For those of you that are at a computer listening to this, if you go to the description, we'll link
the tweet that we're talking about, or you can just look up Nogli on Twitter.
But what you should be doing anyway, to follow him at Nogli Nogli.
Nogli Nogli.
Nogli Nogli Nogli.
Nogli twice.
Dude, you were, you actually made me really wonder.
So you mentioned like most of the time you see something, you don't try and bypass it.
Does your whole automation system and all the alerts, do you have it alert you for like non-findings,
if that makes sense?
Like stuff that is weird, but needs probably a little bit of extra like human effort to fully
exploit, or do you just sort of just cut your losses with that stuff?
And yeah, I have some kind of automation that alerts me for new interesting domain.
It just became publicly accessible and stuff like that.
So it's not a finding, but with a quick look, I could probably see if there is anything here to
explore or not.
I wish I could, you know, make something with FAF and directory good for like most
common 10,000 words, but it's, it's very much, it's hard asset, but you could find some
good stuff with it if you keep monitoring your stuff over and over.
So I'm looking at, I'm looking at this tweet and I don't know, what is it?
Like the fifth, fifth tweet down or whatever you talk about receiving the CF-cache-status
response set to dynamic, right?
So normally when you see dynamic, you know, that's like a bummer, right?
Because it's, it knows that you're not, you know, that this is changing content, but it's,
it's still an interesting thing that that indicates you that there is some caching mechanism
in place, right?
So then, you know, from there you can sort of, uh, you know, for any of you that aren't
super familiar with webcache reception, you should absolutely go find this tweet because
he does a brilliant job of, of outlining how it actually works.
And you even show the default cached file extensions from cloudflare in there, which
I did not have a list of before.
So that's, um, that's really awesome.
And it might even be cool to even build some automation that tries all of these endpoints
or tries all of these extensions and on every single one, because maybe they fixed like the
one for PNG and JPG or even WAF.
But like some of this stuff, like, you know, uh, what is this dot ZST?
I've never heard of that.
Some weird extensions over there.
Yeah.
Have you already turned this into an automation or is this just sort of like a one-off?
It's hard because everything that relates to endpoint, it's very hard.
I didn't figure it out.
I know some people did, but using GAO and having, you know, show a small amount of output.
Eventually it's very, it's super hard problem.
Uh, I mean, to find API is unauthenticated and stuff like that.
So I didn't really do any automation with it.
Well, this is a really impactful one.
So then after you put, you know, test.css at the end, it cached the response.
And then from an unauthenticated perspective, anybody could come hit slash test css.
And we would find your, your, uh, off access token.
Right?
Yeah.
I tried it with Joel.
We went to his VPN and just, you know, he went to my link.
Then I go to JWT and now I see all these interactions, you know?
So what you're saying is Joel has your access token to chat GPT.
No, no, no, no, he has mine.
Oh no.
Joel, you fool.
I know.
I'm doomed.
He's going to steal my bugs.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh.
That's great.
Um, okay, cool.
So let's, let's hit, uh, that SSRF then.
So this was a really fun bug.
I'll intro it for you, for you, Nogli.
Um, this was a bug that Nogli and I, and a couple other people found at a live hacking
event that we went to recently.
And, um, yeah, I think it's just a really good example of collaboration taking things a
little bit, a little bit further.
And also just like a pretty, you know, when you think about SSRF as a vuln type,
you think about hitting internal, internal assets and stuff like that.
But there are some other, uh, things that you should be keeping your eye out for,
which we'll learn about in just a sec.
So Nogli hit us with the details on that one.
Yes.
It was the final day of the on-site event.
So we were hacking for like two weeks for this very, very small web app.
And I just, you know, someone taught me, Jonathan Borman, if you know him,
he's a doctor and he's a hacker as well.
So he just taught me how to use a Burp Active Scanner.
I never use it before because it's, it's never, it never finishes.
So I, I, I just said, why not, why not just fire it over my, uh, my record data.
And it found the most weird SSRF that no one could ever found.
Because for every endpoint that I crawled, it just tried to end /htp and,
you know, the Burp Collab URL.
And you will never, you would never try it on the endpoint that it actually found it.
So when I opened my computer at night, just, you know, we were hacking late night in your room.
And then, uh, I just saw, oh, what is this weird external DNS interaction alert?
And then we saw we actually had SSRF on the instance.
And when we, when I looked at my collaborator, so we saw there is a JWT.
So it was only external.
It was like, you could say blind SSRF, but when you point to your server, it included a JWT for super admin.
And then, you know, we try to, to see how further, how far can we take this vulnerability to.
So we, no one would ever find it if we, you weren't just fuzzing some weird endpoints in parts.
And it's one of the best, the most critical bug in the event also.
Yeah, man.
That was such a fun one because it literally like, you know, we were like, okay.
And when you see where it injects the payload, it literally injects, you know,
normally when you've got an SSRF, it's like, okay, you know, clearly a URL, it goes here.
Or like a host name goes here.
And then we can manipulate that.
This was just like.
Six directories, deep, something.
Yeah.
And it was just like, slap it at the end of the URL with HTTPS included in everything.
And it would just hit that.
So that was, that was kind of nuts, actually.
I still don't understand fully how that happened on the backend, but, um, yeah,
having that bearer leak is, was really, was really huge.
And I've seen this at a couple of different life hacking events as well.
So whenever you get a call back on your Burp collaborator, don't just, you know,
freak out and, you know, start thinking about, Hey, what, what sort of internal stuff can I hit?
Double click into the request, read it thoroughly.
Look at the user agent.
Look at the authorization.
Look at any other headers that are going along there that might indicate to you what kind of
softwares are being used or what kind of additional information is being leaked.
And you might end up with a best bug of the event, like not only here.
So, oh wait, hold on.
Yeah.
This is another opportunity for me to do.
Amazing.
Yeah.
It's super interesting.
The Burp active, active scan stuff, because that's one of those features.
I also like never touch.
There's a lot of features in Burp that I just like, they either didn't work for me one
time and I just stopped using them or I don't fully understand the best way to use them.
And I just like skip over them.
And now I'm going to have to, now I'm going to go learn how to use it.
Yeah.
So give us the rundown.
I mean, what did he teach you there, Natalie?
I mean, I think it broke for me again, because it doesn't finish for me today as well.
But he actually just showed me that you can untick some stuff and then it won't run forever, you know?
Uh, so you can untick the scans, like it, you know, like, all right, should I like, you know,
download this whole JavaScript file and analyze it for six hours button.
Yeah.
You don't want it to look for, for all the stuff, the Zip Zipping, Dome XSS, you know, some stuff.
You want to focus on the stuff it's might to help you, you know, with the most critical and the,
and high stuff.
And you want it to finish.
This is the most important part.
Yeah.
So creating your own custom scan profiles.
That's a, that's a pro tip right there.
So you get more value out of, out of Burt, because I think, you know, it's a little bit designed
for taking a long time and someone who's just really like, you know, the, the, the red team person
for their, for their company or whatever.
And it's just going to let this scan run for forever.
And, and you know, as a bug bounty hunter, we've got a little bit of a different agenda there.
So creating your own scan profiles.
That's a good, that's a good takeaway there.
Um, all right.
We are just over the hour mark.
Um, I, since we finished the reports, I think, uh, that's all I got.
Joel, you got any, anything you want to pick Natalie's brain about?
Yeah, that, that was it.
I mean, this was awesome.
Yeah.
Just getting to hear your insights about how, how you approach things and how you set
things up and how your whole recon works and all that kind of stuff.
And it's really exciting to see you building it into a product too.
Yeah, for sure.
Nagly, you got anything you want to, uh, you want to share here at the end?
Anything you want to promote?
Um, no, I will promote the podcast.
You know, if you're listening to this podcast, you should listen to the podcast.
And, and, uh, it's not, it's not very good to generate leads from, from the ones who are already
listening, but it was great speaking with you.
And yeah.
What a guy, what a guy.
She's using his, his 15 seconds here at the end to promote the, the podcast.
I will say though, I will say, you know, we were, we've, we've, you know, from time to time,
we'll be like, we'll come on here and we'll be like, Hey, you know, please, you know, subscribe on.
What the heck?
Sorry.
Something fell off my wall.
We'll say, you know, subscribe on YouTube or whatever, but one of the biggest ways that
podcasts grow, uh, and we also talk about the hacker chat, so it's really relevant is word of
mouth, you know?
So drop, drop, if you, you know, do us a solid, do give Nagly some pay for his, for his, uh,
his trip on here and share the podcast, uh, in your, your hacker chats or your discords
or whatever, and, or even tell a friend in person.
And because Nagly was so kind to shout out the pod instead of shouting himself out,
I will say definitely keep an eye on shockwave.
Um, his, his, uh, his startup that he's doing, um, you can find it.
We'll link it in the, in the description of the podcast as well.
And, uh, yeah, I think, I think that's about it.
That's the pod.
Yeah.
That's fine.
All right.
Sweet.
Thanks for listening, everybody.
Peace.
Thank you very much.